madame la Présidente merci Monsieur le
Ministre madame la ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales mes chers collègues nous le
savons tous ici sur ces bancs la crise
de notre système de santé et les
difficultés d'accès aux soins qui ont
résultent près de malheureusement pour
nous concitoyens comme pour les
soignants des allures de jours sans fin
cette crise est ancienne c'est un long
délitement ressort complexe qui doit
autant au manque d'anticipation que les
visions malthusienne est conservatrices
qu'on partageait longtemps de nombreux
gouvernements et de nombreux acteurs
représentatifs de la profession pour
autant au-delà des causes sur lesquelles
on pourrait disserter pendant longtemps
mais qui ne sont pas le sujet ce soir
cette crise menace l'un des ciment de
notre pacte républicain la promesse d'un
égal accès pour tous à une prise en
charge médicale qui allie la proximité
la qualité et la graduation des soins en
fonction des besoins le tout dans un
système universel qui doit assurer la
protection de chacun
la proposition de loi que j'ai l'honneur
de rapporter devant vous procède de
conviction que nous sommes nombreux je
le sais à partager sur ses bancs c'est
la conviction qu'il est temps de faire
plus confiance aux acteurs de terrain
pour faire émerger une organisation des
soins à la mesure des besoins et des
aspirations de chaque territoire c'est
la conviction qu'il est temps de
faciliter au plus près du terrain le
partage et les coopérations entre tous
ceux qui directement ou indirectement
participe à cette mission du soin les
professionnels de tous statut bien sûr
mais aussi les collectivités locales les
administrations et les associations de
patients le temps est venu d'accélérer
un virage déjà opéré ces dernières
années notamment par la loi ma santé
2022 voulu par le président Emmanuel
Emmanuel Macron et son premier ministre
d'alors Edouard Philippe qui vise à
considérer que l'avenir de notre système
de santé passe autant par des réformes
structurelles nationales à l'exemple du
sel du financement qui est annoncé pour
le prochain pfss que par la
responsabilisation des acteurs de
proximité pour faire émerger des
réponses adaptées aux spécificités de
chaque territoire
il revient à l'État au gouvernement et à
la représentation nationale de définir
les règles générales les prio les
priorités attendues de notre système
d'assurance maladie et de veiller au
financement de l'ensemble mais il
revient aux acteurs de terrain de
réfléchir et d'imaginer ensemble en
fonction des besoins propres à chacun la
déclinaison territoriale de ces
priorités nationales
je pense au virage vers la prévention je
pense au meilleur partage de la
permanence des soins je pense encore à
la meilleure répartition des forces
soignantes dans les territoires qui
mieux que les acteurs de terrain
connaissent les besoins en santé de la
population dont ils ont la charge des
Français inquiets face à ce délitement
de leur système de santé des soignants
soumis au contrats d'un système trop
administré et de patients déboussolés le
temps est venu pour que de ces bancs
émergent des mesures pragmatiques
concrètes utiles d'abord pour nos
concitoyens qui en permanence nous
interpellent sur ce sujet mais aussi
pour les professionnels de santé qui en
ville comme à l'hôpital attendent des
évolutions
pour rénover un système de santé trop
atomisé cloisonné déséquilibré avec les
acteurs qui ne portent pas tous les
mêmes obligations avec des secteurs de
la ville et de l'hôpital qui ne
communiquent pas assez et avec trop de
nombreux professionnels qui existent
encore de façon isolée nous sommes
appelés à prendre des mesures fortes
personne n'a toutefois de baguette
magique et tout le monde sait notamment
ici qu'il n'y a pas de solution miracle
pour autant les débats au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales nous
ont montré que sur ce thème primordial
nous pouvions converger vers des
solutions concrètes tant sur des mesures
ciblées que sur des réformes
structurelles place désormais à l'action
et un impulsion d'une dynamique nouvelle
pour renforcer l'accès aux soins et
rénover nos systèmes de santé qui
comptent encore quoi qu'en disent
certains parmi nos trésors nationaux il
nous faut faciliter la coopération entre
les différents acteurs soignant du
public et du privé élu locaux et leur
service agent de l'État et des
organismes sociaux représentant les
patients en les faisant travailler
ensemble de manière plus efficace pour
améliorer la prise en charge et le
parcours des patients
nous devons ainsi nous inspirer la
démarche du Conseil national de la
refondation consacrée à la santé
souhaité par le Président de la
République en réunissant dans les
bassins de vie l'ensemble des partis
prenantes de la santé la proposition de
loi que nous allons examiner aujourd'hui
pour vocation à faire d'abord confiance
à l'intelligence collective et à la
créativité du terrain pour faire émerger
des stratégies en santé adaptées à
chaque territoire ces principes sont
l'ADN de ce texte l'article premier
organise le dialogue la concertation et
le partage de stratégie commune en santé
en donnant du poids et du sens au
Conseil territoriaux de santé créé par
la loi de Marisol Touraine de 2016 ses
conseils territoriaux de santé sont
aujourd'hui souvent des coquilles vides
demain cela ne sera plus le cas
puisqu'ils auront pour mission
d'élaborer le projet territorial de
santé d'assurer son suivi ainsi que
l'évaluation de sa mise en oeuvre en
lien avec les agences régionales de
santé afin de donner du sens à la
gouvernance territoriale il définiront
demain les objectifs prioritaires en
matière de permanence des soins d'accès
aux soins et d'équilibres territorial de
l'offre de soins le dispos itif tend à
responsabiliser les acteurs de terrain
sur la nécessaire réduction des
inégalités de densité démographique
c'est une mesure importante à l'heure ou
plus de 1,6 millions de Français
renoncent chaque année à des soins
médicaux
la composition du conseil territorial de
santé est renforcé tous les acteurs du
territoire doivent se coordonner autour
de stratégies qu'il mettront ensuite en
œuvre nous souhaitons ainsi donner un
coup d'accélérateur aux communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
les fameuses CPTs organisation propre
aux soins de ville on y rattachant
automatiquement les professionnels de
santé et les centres de santé dans les
territoires auxquels ils appartiennent
déjà aujourd'hui certaines CPTs sont
construit des projets aboutis en
proposant une prise en charge plus
efficace des patients comme c'est le cas
dans ma circonscription du Sud
Seine-et-Marne il convient désormais
d'aller plus loin que ccpts FEDER plus
de soignants libéraux et d'accélérer
leur déploiement partout en France c'est
toute l'ambition de l'article 3
20 ans après la suppression l'obligation
de garde pour les médecins de ville il
est temps que nous opérions à
rééquilibrage entre tous les
professionnels qui doivent pouvoir mieux
participer à la permanence des soins la
permanence des soins en ambulatoire a
été précisée par la par la récente loi
de Stéphanie Rist l'article cap de cette
proposition de loi est complémentaire de
cette disposition récentes et prévoit
que les établissements de santé privé
participeront davantage à la permanence
des soins aux côtés des hôpitaux il
s'agit d'une mesure de bon sens soutenue
par les représentants des établissements
privés la principale difficulté notre
système de santé tient aussi à la
démographie médicale nous n'avons pas
assez de professionnels de santé pour
répondre aux besoins et les années qui
viennent s'annoncent encore plus
difficiles avec des tensions extrêmes
dans les zones sous dotées notamment
l'article 5 étant ainsi le contrat
d'engagement de service public à tous
les professionnels en médecine
onthontologie maïotique et pharmacie à
l'issue de la deuxième année du premier
cycle des études de santé ce qui
constitue un plus pour lutter contre les
déserts médicaux
parce que le maintien de l'offre de
soins dans un territoire donné est une
priorité les articles 9 et 10 qui ont
d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'un dialogue
étroit avec l'ensemble des ordres
concernés et les syndicats des padus
vise à renforcer l'intégration des
praticiens à diplômes hors Union
Européenne leur exercice sera alors
facilité avec l'autre croix selon les
cas d'une autorisation d'exercice
provisoire ou d'une nouvelle carte de
séjour plus réelle l'article 7 de son
côté vise à interdire l’exercice de
l'intérim en début de carrière pour tous
les soignants ce dispositif permet aux
jeunes professionnels d'accéder à des
modes d'exercice stables et de ne pas
augmenter la pénurie sur les postes de
titulaire aussi bien des établissements
de santé que dans les cabinets de ville
nous savons également que la refonte du
système de santé doit passer par une
évolution du fonctionnement de l'hôpital
c'est pourquoi l'article 6 prévoit de
simplifier la conduite de projets à
l'échelle des groupements hospitaliers
de territoire et à ce propos je me
réjouis de l'adoption en commission des
affaires sociales d'un amendement qui
tend à élargir les pouvoirs de
délibération du conseil de surveillance
dans le but de réaffirmer le rôle
stratégique de cet instant dans la
gouvernance hospitalière
enfin nous avons tous en tête l'affaire
Européa elle a mis en lumière la
complexité des montages juridiques
utilisés par les établissements privés
qui avaient rendu aveugle les autorités
de régulation face à des pratiques
contraires à l'éthique voire
frauduleuses nous proposons ainsi de
renforcer le contrôle financier sur les
cliniques privées leur satellite et les
sociétés qui les contrôlent chers
collègues chers collègues je sais au
combien le sujet de la santé nous touche
tous dans nos circonscriptions le nombre
d'amendements déposés par les députés de
tous les groupes le montre bel et bien
l'amélioration de l'accès aux soins ne
peut être l'oeuvre d'un seul parti
politique et je me réjouis de la
co-construction sur ce texte en amont de
sa discussion ce soir
à l'exemple bien sûr des auditions
nombreuses auxquelles j'ai procédé mais
aussi des discussions nourries
fructueuses que j'ai eu avec le groupe
de travail conduit à la fois par
Guillaume Garraud et Philippe bigier
étant d'autres ces discussions ont
permis de dessiner de nombreuses
convergences je remercie ainsi ainsi les
parlementaires pour la qualité des
débats en commission des affaires
sociales de leur volonté de faire bouger
les lignes en proposant les solutions
concrètes sans faire de l'obstruction à
l'heure où la santé et la préoccupation
majeure des Français de nombreuses
avancées concrètes ont été adoptées je
m'en satisfait qu'à car elles vont dans
le bon sens je pense par exemple à la
mise en place d'un préavis de six mois
au médecin au chirurgien-dentiste et au
sage-femme avant qu'il quitte leur lieu
d'exercice cela doit permettre aux
autorités d'anticiper chaque situation
et de disposer du temps nécessaire pour
s'organiser afin que l'accès aux soins
continuent d'être assuré
l'investissement de mes collègues du
groupe Horizon a également été entiers
avec notamment l'adoption d'un
amendement qui vise à ouvrir aux maisons
de santé et cabinet libéraux en zone
soudance le bénéfice de la mise à
disposition de fonctionnaires
territoriaux cela constitue un oubli un
outil supplémentaire à la destination
des collectivités territoriales iales
dans la lutte contre les déserts
médicaux j'en ai la conviction beaucoup
de points feront encore l'objet de débat
et ce texte sera amélioré certainement
par l'examen en séance publique bien sûr
la proposition de loi ne répondra pas à
l'ensemble des problèmes qui visent qui
pourraient résoudre la question de notre
système de santé bien malade je le
disais mais elle constitue une réponse
utile une réponse concrète pour
l'ensemble des soignants mais aussi
surtout pour l'ensemble des Français qui
nous le qui ne l'oublions pas sont les
premiers perdants face à un système de
santé qui est aujourd'hui à genoux merci
de votre écoute
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés
le fonctionnement de notre système de
santé est complexe trop administré trop
centralisé
je crois qu'il y a deux temps dans
l'histoire de notre système de santé et
plus largement de nos institutions
j'ai un immense respect pour ceux qui
ont bâti notre système national de
protection sociale à l'époque où nous
avions besoin d'un pouvoir central
directeur et exhaustif pour reconstruire
un pays meurtri faire le constat
aujourd'hui des limites de ce modèle ne
revient pas à nier la grandeur des
choses érigées au contraire moderniser
le fonctionnement de notre système de
santé pour l'adapter aux défis et aux
réalités de notre temps est une
nécessité pour le préserver et pour que
la promesse intangible de soins adaptés
et de qualité accessible pour tous et
partout continue de bénéficier aux
générations actuelles et futures
c'est réunir ces deux temps de notre
histoire
le moment tout à fait exceptionnel de la
crise sanitaire de la colite 19 a imposé
se fait avec une acuité nouvelle alors
qu'au fil des vagues épidémiques ont été
inventées partout en France de nouvelles
solutions et que localement se sont
tissés des solidarités nouvelles
ce dont notre pays et notre système de
santé a besoin en 2023 c'est d'ouverture
d'agilité et de confiance pour les
acteurs de santé et dans les territoires
et tout cela au service des Françaises
et des Français
j'y reviendrai mais rien ne serait pire
que de lier dans la loi les mains des
acteurs de la santé les empêchant
d'avoir cette agilité si essentielle
face aux défis que nous connaissons
en effet si l'État doit rester le garant
des valeurs qui fondent notre système et
que c'est au niveau national que doivent
être définis des grandes priorités
l'enjeu est aujourd'hui de faciliter
l'émergence de réponse territoriale
avec communic horizon l'amélioration de
l'accès aux soins et la lutte contre
toutes les inégalités de santé notamment
géographiques
pour transformer le fonctionnement et
l'organisation territoriale de notre
système de santé afin qu'il réponde à
ses objectifs il n'y a pas vous l'avez
dit monsieur le rapporteur de solution
miracle
nous faisons face à une crise
démographique il ne s'agit pas ici de
régler des comptes à posteriori mais
dénoncer un fait
nous avons trop longtemps voulu
rationner l'offre pour réduire les coûts
notamment à travers le numerus clausus
c'est un acquis important de cette
majorité de l'avoir supprimé lors du
mandat précédent nous conduisant
progressivement à former plus de
professionnels déjà plus 15% par an en
moyenne
je le sais cela n'est pas encore assez
je sais aussi combien cette solution
pèse sur les soignants et que certains
font face à des situations de véritables
épuisement j'en suis bien conscient et
nous allons continuer collectivement les
forts je pense notamment à ce que nous
faisons avec les régions pour former
plus
mais je tiens à le dire nous ne
supprimerons pas les déserts médicaux et
nous ne réglerons pas les difficultés
structurelles qui parcourent notre
système de santé d'un coup de baguette
le dire serait faux le faire croire
serait malhonnête
par exemple j'entends souvent dire à
propos de l'hôpital à la lecture des
courriers que vous m'envoyez mais
pourquoi ne recrutez-vous pas tant de
milliers d'infirmiers ou d'aide
soignants des postes sont belles et bien
ouverts et nous travaillons sur
l'attractivité de ces métiers mais nous
n'avons pas encore suffisamment de
professionnels de santé pour couvrir ses
postes
je crois qu'avec constance et ambition
nous arriverons tous ensemble à mettre
en place les outils et les organisations
qui permettent dans chaque territoire de
trouver des solutions aux défis aux
besoins de la population
cette méthode je la déploie depuis mon
arrivée au ministère de la santé et de
la prévention
elle s'incarne notamment dans la
démarche du Conseil national de
refondation en santé qui a permis par le
rassemblement des citoyens élus et
professionnels de santé autour de la
co-construction de ces solutions locales
de donner un souffle et un souffle
nouveau à cette idée de démocratie
ensemble santé cette méthode elle prend
encore aussi dans toutes les réformes
que nous travaillons avec vous au
Parlement ma politique vous le savez
n'est pas celle de l'immobilisme mais
celle de la recherche de l'adhésion à un
projet collectif
je l'ai dit d'entrer ce texte inscrit
dans un chantier plus large au service
de nos concitoyens et au service de nos
professionnels il s'inscrit dans la
continuité des travaux que nous menons
ensemble et qui ont déjà permis
l'aboutissement de plusieurs textes
importants qui participent à cette
action globale j'ai pu citer la loi
riste mais aussi la loi katabi qui
renforce le contrôle des centres de
santé et qui a servi de modèles à ce que
nous mettons en place dans ce texte pour
le contrôle des cliniques privées et de
leur société satellite
aussi mesdames et messieurs les députés
avant de passer de relais à la ministre
délégué à Firma le Baudot je tiens à
saluer tous les députés qui se
mobilisent autour de ce texte important
pour améliorer la santé et renforcer
l'accès aux soins de nos concitoyens
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
nous avons pu construire ensemble des
apports pertinents au texte aussi bien
avec la majorité qu'avec les oppositions
constructives preuve que sans renier nos
différences politiques nous pouvons
travailler au service de l'intégrer
général au fond le seul qui compte
je ne doute pas que cet état d'esprit
sera le nôtre pour l'ensemble des débats
à venir je vous remercie
je vous remercie la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle la suite de la
discussion de la proposition de loi
visant à améliorer l'accès aux soins par
l'engagement territorial des
professionnels et hier soir l'assemblée
à poursuivi l'examen des articles
s'arrêtant aux amendements numéro 1 et
identiques portant article additionnels
après l'article 2
amendement pouvant être soumis à une
discussion commune amendement numéro 1
et identique faisant l'objet de
sous-amendement amendement
identique amendement numéro 1 monsieur
garrot merci madame la Présidente
alors
je défends ici un amendement au nom du
groupe de travail trans partisan que
nous avons constitué ici à l'Assemblée
voilà près d'un an
et je voudrais présenter
le sens de la
régularigulation de l'installation tel
que nous la proposons d'abord il faut
dire ce qu'elle n'est pas cette
régulation ce que nous proposons ce
n'est pas d'affecter les médecins ici ou
là j'ai entendu des choses qui étaient
parfaitement fausses de ce point de vue
nous n'allons pas nommer un médecin dans
tel ou tel territoire en revanche ce que
nous disons c'est la chose suivante nous
disons à nos médecins
n'allez plus vous installer là où les
besoins de soins sont déjà pourvus
mais allez vous installer où vous
voudrez
ailleurs là où les besoins de santé ne
sont pas pourvus là où vos patients vous
attendent
c'est l'idée cette régulation que nous
devons aujourd'hui
organiser l'installation en fonction des
besoins de santé des territoires
et pour cela nous proposons un régime
d'autorisation qui serait accordé ou pas
par les agences régionales de santé
pourquoi nous faisons cette proposition
pour une raison simple nous partons du
constat de ce que nous vivons de ce que
vivent des millions de Français
aujourd'hui
on fait tous la même démonstration je
crois les uns les autres c'est que les
politiques d'un citations qui ont été
menées depuis des années depuis des
dizaines d'années non pas produit les
résultats qu'on attendait
je voudrais pour ça me référer à l'Atlas
de la démographie médicale qui a été
publié le 1er janvier dernier oui je
vais faire court mais ça vaut le coup
quand même madame la Présidente c'est
pas moi qui vais vous dire le contraire
mais deux minutes c'est deux minutes
monsieur le député donc il va falloir en
tout cas
un chiffre très simple et je vais
ensuite m'arrêter là pour reprendre
éventuellement ensuite mais depuis 10
ans plus de 10 ans entre 2010 et 2023 la
densité de médecins par habitant a
augmenté je dis bien augmenter de 27%
dans les Hautes-Alpes pour diminuer de
15 merci je suis désolé amendement
numéro 2 monsieur Vigier amendement
numéro 2 vous allez prendre brillamment
la suite le sous-amand non sera vu après
tous les amendements identiques monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales
depuis 30 ans on constate les uns et les
autres une dégradation de l'accès aux
soins
qui peut dire le contraire ici personne
et pourtant
et pourtant j'ai entendu des mini j'ai
entendu des rapporteurs j'entendais des
parlementaires surtout les bons au Sénat
à l'Assemblée essayez d'ouvrir des
pistes et puis ce qui ont été ouverts
mais qui à l'heure actuelle s'avère
comme chacun sait totalement insuffisant
parce qu'on a encore 7 à 8 années devant
nous extrêmement difficile on a ouvert
la délégation de taxes on a commencé à
avancer avec les IPA
on a constaté qu'il y avait des zones
dans lesquelles l'accès aux soins serai
plus encore et qui a des record des
quelques poches où il y avait une
densité qui était plus importante
qu'ailleurs d'ailleurs on a fait un test
en direct monsieur le ministre je vous
invite à le faire avec nous vous
cherchez un médecin généraliste à Nice
vous allez voir qu'il y a 40 rendez-vous
qui vont monter immédiatement
si vous en cherchez un homme à ma
commune nous on a monté les soins non
programmés que vous savez donc ça nous
permet quand même d'apporter une réponse
donc ce que nous proposons ça dépend une
régulation drastique ça dépend de la
coercition ça n'est pas envoyé des
internes dans les territoires sudotés
c'est pas cela ce que nous disons c'est
là où la densité est suffisante c'est un
départ plat à plaque c'est très simple
c'est un mètre 5 qui part à la retraite
c'est un autre qui arrive donc on peut
pas me faire la musique de dire cette
zone là vous allez la rendre soudance
c'est pas vrai on reste au même niveau
et les autres c'est pas beaucoup certes
ça sera 300 400 installations par an où
là ça nous permettra de les envoyer à
quelques kilomètres du moins il y a une
liberté totale qui reste sur 93% du
territoire français liberté totale par
rapport à d'autres métiers réglementés
par rapport aux infirmiers au kiné aux
pharmaciens ou d'autres je pense pas que
l'effort soit considérable d'ailleurs je
termine monsieur le ministre en vous
disant que
la difficulté vous le savez vous l'avez
dit vous-même 11% des médecins
s'installe pour des raisons
d'attractivité et pour des raisons
simples yo fait que par exemple et vous
le savez parce que je sais que d'avancer
en partage je termine madame la
Présidente pense pas que la convention à
26,50 € sur la meilleure réponse qu'on
peut leur apporter sachant que eux
soignent les patients et qu'ils ont
besoin d'une reconnaissance à l'automne
leur formation merci monsieur le député
amendement attendez avant
je vous informe que je suis saisie sur
le vote des amendements numéro 1 et
identiques d'une novembre de scrutin
public formulé par les groupes
Renaissance France insoumise démocrates
socialiste écologiste je suis également
saisie par le groupe renaissance de
demande de scrutin public sur tous les
amendements portant articles après
article 2 les scrutins sont annoncés
dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
amendement numéro 3 monsieur
me réjouir de ce débat et féliciter
notre rapporteur pour la qualité de son
texte qui a enfin et au moins le mérite
d'aborder l'un des tous premiers sujets
de préoccupation quotidienne de nos
concitoyens je veux parler bien sûr de
leurs difficultés d'accéder aux soins et
des inégalités territoriales que cela
engendre mais si ce texte a le mérite
d'exister il est malheureusement encore
trop timide puisqu'il reste figé sur un
ADN qui n'a pas suffisamment et c'est un
euphémisme apportait la preuve de son
efficacité sur le terrain je veux parler
des incitations de quelques natures
qu'elles soient développées depuis plus
de 20 ans avec l'absence criante de
résultats que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui c'est à dire plus de 8
millions de compatriotes qui n'ont pas
de médecins c'est pourquoi je salue
l'initiative de mon collègue et ami
mayenney Guillaume Garraud à laquelle
j'ai immédiatement souscrit de
rassembler des députés venus de
différents horizons politiques autour
d'une idée claire et de bon sens la
régulation de l'installation cette
régulation ce n'est pas une punition
pour les médecins mais c'est une
solution pour français parallèlement et
en complément des incitations une
solution qui a fait ses preuves pour
d'autres professions telles que les
infirmiers les kinés et les pharmaciens
et qui fonctionnent dans d'autres pays
tels que la Belgique le Danemark ou le
Québec il n'y a rien de scandaleux ni de
honteux à orienter l'installation des
médecins là où on a vraiment besoin de
alors Monsieur le Ministre pourquoi ne
pas expérimenter la régulation afin que
ces cette inégalité républicaine
intolérable et un supportable c'est
l'objet de l'amendement transpartisan
que nous vous proposons c'est un
complément indispensable aux politiques
publiques déjà en place entre lesquels
il est nécessaire et naturel de trouver
un équilibre je vous remercie merci
monsieur le député l'amendement numéro
98 monsieur califer
oui merci Madame Brice monsieur le
ministre la présidente de commission
monsieur vapoteur
c'est un abonnement
issu des travaux du groupe de travail
transportant créer et piloter par notre
collègue Guillaume Garraud qui vise tout
simplement à réguler l'installation des
médecins généralistes spécialistes
et des chirurgiens dentistes vers les
zones au Louvre de soins est
insuffisante il y en a pour se faire il
crée une autorisation d'installation des
médecins et des chirurgiens dentistes
délivrés par l'ARS il ne s'agit donc pas
de revenir sur la liberté d'installation
mais bien de l'encadrer mais aussi
d'inciter à une installation des
médecins en zone peu dense là maintenant
proposer ainsi vous pose ainsi la remise
d'un rapport qui permettra un complément
de formulation des propositions afin de
cibler des aides à l'installation des
aides un peu plus ciblées on va dire
vers les stations vers les zones où
l'offre de soins est plus désagréable
plus dégradé où il y en a pas du tout
pour ne pas froisser les uns les autres
proposons les solutions pour nous
permettre de mieux traverser les 7
années qui viennent car nous savons il
n'y aura pas de médecin avant 7 ans donc
donnez les moyens de pouvoir soigner au
plus près la population c'est un travail
très sportisant redonnant au Parlement
sa mission de légiférer avec une
majorité parlementaire qui s'est
construite autour de ce texte merci
merci monsieur le député
la maman 269
présidente monsieur le ministre sur le
rapporteur madame la Présidente de
commission mes chers collègues je crois
qu'il est important dans ce débat tout
d'abord de se mettre d'accord sur le
diagnostic si le manque de médecins est
un fait c'est leur répartition inégale
sur le territoire qui n'est plus
tolérable oui il y a un problème de
démographie médicale de notre pays non
ils ne s'oppose pas avec la même acuité
dans tous les territoires vous le
sauriez d'ailleurs si vous habitiez sur
l'Ardèche Méridionale ou la Montagne
Ardéchoise un bassin de santé Soudan ce
niveau médical avec 100000 habitants
hiver 300000 habitants l'été et avec un
hôpital Aubenas à deux heures du premier
CHU venaison venons-en maintenant au
remède car rien ne sert de mettre un
sparadrap sur une jambe de bois l'enjeu
c'est bien évidemment de former plus de
médecins d'en former le double et de
veiller à leur bonne répartition
géographique quand vous prenez le nombre
de médecins généralistes pour 100000
habitants les écarts entre les
départements vont du simple au triple de
1 à 6 d'ailleurs pour les spécialistes
l'Ardèche n'est pas la Gironde la Creuse
n'est pas les Alpes-Maritimes et les
Vosges ne sont pas Paris intra-muros
voilà pourquoi nous proposons le temps
de former plus de médecins de ne pas en
installer de nouveau dans les zones les
mieux dotées en tout cas tant qu'il n'y
a pas de départ de médecin constaté je
crois que c'est une façon d'apporter un
peu d'oxygène au système l'entorse aux
principes de liberté installation ne me
paraît ne nous paraît pas fondamental et
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre cette
régulation soft pourrait être au cœur
des discussions avec les médecins plus
nombreux demain mieux considérer via la
revalorisation de la consultation et
celle du statut d’interne qui est aussi
certainement au cœur du débat et de
grâce pour conclure moins de
bureaucratie tous les professionnels de
santé nous le demandent merci monsieur
le député à maintenant 562 monsieur Nury
tout ça est un échec il ne nous reste
que 150 généralistes pour 280000
habitants dans l'Orne donc il faut
rapidement et urgemment réguler
l'installation des médecins pour faire
en sorte qu'ils ne puissent plus
s'installer dans les tiroirs surdossés
et il y en a et soit donc encouragé à
venir dans les zones déficidaires c'est
un impératif monsieur ministre merci
monsieur le député
[Applaudissements]
834 madame minier
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues je ne compte pas le nombre de
concitoyens concitoyennes qui m'a l'air
sur la difficulté à trouver un médecin
et je pense que nous sommes nombreux
dans cette émission le dernier message
en date j'ai interpellé plusieurs fois
l'ARS sur le manque de médecin on m'a
dit que je n'aurais jamais dû
m'installer dans un désert médical
c'est donc pour apporter une réponse à
nos concitoyens et concitoyennes que je
me joins à mes collègues du groupe
transpartisan pour défendre aujourd'hui
la régulation de l'installation des
médecins en fonction des besoins des
territoires
chez moi en Bretagne la moitié des
communes ne comptait aucun médecin
généraliste en 2021 sur ma
circonscription 56 communes sur 59 ou un
accès inférieur à la moyenne au médecin
généraliste quel que soit leur tarif
aujourd'hui l'accès aux soins n'est
clairement pas le même sur l'ensemble du
territoire ce que nous proposons n'est
en rien une mesure coercitive nous
souhaitons orienter les médecins vers
des territoires qui manquent cruellement
de professionnels de santé je vous
remercie merci madame la députée
l'amendement 983 monsieur Clouet
merci madame la Présidente ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui en séance est tout à
fait extraordinaire et intéressant
puisque je suis là en train de défendre
un amendement qui rigoureusement le même
que celui qu'on défendu juste avant moi
les collègues favnik ou Vigier qui ne
siège pas sur le même groupe que moi
parfois même pas du tout dans le même
groupe que moi et pourtant nous nous
retrouvons sur ce type de mesure qui
suscite un consensus transpartisan
extrême en large ce consensus il était
inscrit dans une réalité qui est
indépassable aujourd'hui 10% des
arrondissements du pays concentre la
moitié des ophtalmo 10% des
moitié des dentistes et face à ce
constat que faire il y a trois options
la première bien sûr on la connaît et
c'est avoir plus de médecins et nous le
souhaitons mais cela signifie attendre
10 ans avant d'en avoir les effets cette
durée est insupportable la deuxième
option c'est multiplier les incitations
mais cela ne fonctionne pas l'argent mis
sur la table va croissant sans que les
effets attendus soit réaliser dès lors
il y a un accord large à nouveau par des
députés de 9 groupes différents pour
vous proposer une forme de régulation ça
signifie ce qui est expliqué juste avant
que partout où l'offre de soins est
bonne en zone surdosée et bien nous
garantissons le maintien de cet offre
par une politique de remplacement
systématique des partantes et des
partants partout en revanche ou l'offre
est insuffisante et bien les
professionnels peuvent venir s'installer
c'est une politique une mesure qui ne
fait que des gagnantes et des gagnants
et qui a l'avantage
de s'inscrire dans une expérience longue
Belgique Allemagne des pays qui ont mis
en place ce type de dispositif et où la
couverture médicale est plus juste et
plus égalitaire elle est également en
vigueur on le sait dans notre pays par
exemple pour les pharmacies la ministre
madame Firmin Baudot connaît très bien
le dossier les pharmaciennes elle est
elle-même régulée donc elle est la
preuve du fait que ça marche la
régulation pour les professions de santé
bref cette option que nous vous
proposons ici doit bien être comprise
comme une solution qui est un compromis
assez général et qui résulte lui-même de
moi et de moi de travail en commun de
réflexion commune et même de meeting en
commun entre des députés que pourtant
par ailleurs quasiment tout oppose
j'espère que vous serez sensible à
l'argument et qu'aujourd'hui la nation
entière pour avancer par notre voix
le sous-amendement numéro 1178 monsieur
Marion
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je vous propose ce sous
amendement pour m'assurer que le rapport
de Vendée par l'amendement de mon
collègue garrot formule bien des
propositions sur le ciblage de toutes
les aides à l'installation vers les
territoires ou l'offre de soins et
dégradé ces incitations viennent
compléter d'ailleurs
utilement la régulation d'installation
sur ce sujet moi je suis heureux de
constater à l'issue de nos deux jours de
débats que nous avons considérablement
progresser alors qu'on me dit depuis des
mois que la France n'est plus qu'un
immense désert médical monsieur le
ministre a mis en avant ces derniers
jours un dispositif incitant les
docteurs juniors de la quatrième année
d'étude de médecine a s'installer dans
des zones soudances reconnaissant des
facto qu'il existe aussi des zones qui
ne sont pas en dessous densité surtout
la régulation d'installation elle a été
actée lors de nos débats j'ai bien
écouté monsieur le rapporteur il nous a
dit oui à la régulation mais quand nous
aurons davantage de médecins c'est un
progrès considérable alors même de prise
de position que je salue on nous
expliquait que la régulation ne
fonctionnait nulle part ce qui
d'ailleurs est en contradiction avec les
conclusions des rapports de l'adresse je
cite les exemples européens vont plutôt
globalement dans le sens d'un impact
positif d'une politique de régulation
des installations sur l'équité de la
distribution géographique donc le débat
s'est déplacé de pour ou contre la
régulation vers quand la mettre en place
maintenant ou en 2030 2035 de mon côté
je continue à penser que cette période
pénurie qu'il faut régler c'est
maintenant que nous avons besoin de
mesures fortes et urgentes et je ne suis
pas le seul à le penser souvenons-nous
ce qui était écrit dans le document de
campagne du président de la République
en 2022 que j'ai distribué comme
d'autres ici pas tous je cite la page 9
lutter contre les déserts médicaux avec
des leviers à construire ensemble deux
points régulation d'installation j'ai à
cœur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai à cœur chers collègues aujourd'hui
de rester fidèle à l'engagement du
militant et de l'étude et de l'élu
locale que j'étais hier merci
amendement 1083
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je voulais commencer mon
propos pour saluer l'engagement du
rapporteur qui a cherché tout au long de
ces travaux qui ne sont pas terminés à
trouver des chemins de dialogue
d'équilibre et de compromis
je veux saluer le ministre ton cabinet
qui on fait preuve d'une écoute
attentive et je veux dire à Guillaume
Garraud et au dizaines de députés du
groupe de travail transpartisans combien
notre travail en commun fait l'honneur
de cette assemblée
à voir su avoir su dépassé nos
étiquettes politiques laisser de côté
nos querelles partisanes pour travailler
ensemble sur un sujet majeur qui est la
préoccupation première des Français la
lutte contre les déserts médicaux
et personnellement cela m'apporte peu de
savoir quelle partie quel groupe
politique dira le bénéfice politique de
la lutte contre les déserts médicaux car
c'est une faillite collective les
responsabilités sont partagées et nous
devons y répondre collectivement tous
ensemble
cela fait des années
écoutez on verra ce que vous voterez
vous irez expliquer à vos électeurs
votre position politique
vous irez dans votre circonscription
expliquez vos positions
les maths finiront par tomber cher
collègue doit tremblement national
[Musique]
continuez à dressez-vous à la présidente
normalement ça calme cela fait des
années que la désertification médicale
progresse que l'on voit année après
année dans nos campagnes les difficultés
d'accès aux soins s'accumulaient que nos
habitants franchissent désespérés les
portes de nos permanences parlementaires
nous demandant de l'aide pour trouver un
médecin alors monsieur le ministre vous
ne direz que la France entière est un
désert médical permettez-moi de citer
quelques chiffres il y a trois fois plus
de médecins généralistes par habitant
trois fois plus de médecins généralistes
par habitant dans les Hautes-Alpes dans
l'Eure 10 fois plus d'ophtalmologue par
habitant à Paris que dans la Creuse 33
fois plus de pédiatres à Paris que dans
l'Indre 5 départements sans aucun
gynécologue libéral merci de conclure
chers collègues je vous dirai simplement
ne caricaturez pas cet amendement cet
amendement c'est pas la punition des
médecins cet amendement c'est pas obligé
les médecins s'installer dans un
territoire dans lequel ils ne veulent
pas c'est un moment c'est simplement
dire que les médecins ne pourront pas
s'installer dans un territoire surdoté
son ex
l'amendement 167
[Applaudissements]
merci Madame merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je vais également commencer
par saluer le travail et le sens de
l'écoute du rapporteur et remercie aussi
le groupe horizon grâce à qui nous avons
enfin au Parlement se débat sur la
régulation aujourd'hui
je veux dire aussi pourquoi je propose
d'aller plus loin
certains nous disent que il n'y a rien à
répartir mais la France notre pays forme
des millions de des milliers de médecins
chaque année ne pas les orienter vers
ceux qui en ont le plus besoin est une
grave grave rupture de promesses
républicaines
celle de l'égalité entre les territoires
et entre tous les citoyens
tous les déserts médicaux ne se valent
pas chez moi la question n'est pas
d'avoir un médecin traitant n'est pas
d'avoir des difficultés à accéder à un
médecin traitant c'est la difficulté
d'avoir accès à un médecin tout court
chaque installation
chaque installation dans une zone
surdotée c'est des parents chez moi qui
n'ont pas de solution pour leurs enfants
c'est une personne âgée qui n'a pas
accès à un médecin c'est quelqu'un qui
ne fera pas une consultation et dont on
découvrira une grave pathologie trop
tard
alors je veux juste redire que c'est un
moment de fierté pour moi aujourd'hui de
porter la parole de nos milliers de
concitoyens sur l'ensemble du territoire
et de le faire avec des collègues de
l'ensemble des groupes de cette
assemblée merci monsieur le député
l'amendement numéro
merci même la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous l'avons évoqué hier soir
depuis de nombreuses années démesure
incitatives ont été mises en oeuvre
elles sont insuffisantes
soumettre l'installation d'un certain
nombre de professionnels les plus
particulièrement les médecins et les
chirurgiens dentistes à autorisation
paraît tout simplement naturel et ça
devrait être le travail des agences
régionales de santé dont les cartes et
les zonages ARS démontrent l'inégalité
de la répartition des médecins dans les
territoires il y a des territoires des
zones sous dotées et d'autres qui sont
un peu mieux dotés dans les territoires
mieux dotés ce qui est proposé c'est de
permettre la cessation d'activité et
l'installation transmission on ne
dépouille pas les territoires bien dotés
par contre on encourage les nouvelles
installations dans les territoires moins
bien dotés et pourquoi ceci parce que
depuis 40 ans nous avons mis en place
les alors le numerus clausus qui vient
de s'ouvrir naturellement mais nous
avons les primes à l'installation la
défiscalisation en zone de
revitalisation rurale les contrats
locaux de santé les communautés
professionnelles de territoire de santé
les infirmières en pratique inversées
les maisons de santé les groupements
spontané de territoire de santé les
centres de santé les médecins salariés
je crois que nous avons essayé beaucoup
de choses aujourd'hui
réguler l'installation des médecins et
des chirurgiens dentistes est
indispensable et c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça que nous avons autant de députés de
différentes circonscriptions qui sont
mobilisées sur cette question et je
souhaite que le rapporteur dans son
expression fasse preuve de compréhension
de mansuétude et surtout qu'il exprime
la sagesse
merci monsieur le député
amendement 968 est-ce que je peux vous
proposer de présenter une 967 avec je
vous remercie
merci Madame la merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues
d'abord je voudrais saluer notre
rapporteur Frédéric valtoux pour avoir
fait cette proposition de loi soutenu
par la majorité parce que c'est bien
cette majorité qui depuis 2017 essaie de
mettre en avant des mesures concrètes
pour la santé des Français pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux et pour
augmenter le temps médical c'est la
suppression du numerus clausus c'est
l'augmentation des places dans les
écoles d'infirmières et d'aide soignante
c'est le Ségur bien sûr ce sont les
aides à l'installation 50000 euros sans
oublier les adrr qui le permettent quand
même je rappelle une exonération d'impôt
sur le revenu durant 5 ans avec parfois
aussi quelques effets de bord tout ça
est utile tout ça fonctionne et il est
vrai de dire qu'aujourd'hui aucun
territoire ne peut se prévaloir d'être
sûr dense la pénurie est quasiment
partout pour autant pour autant il y a
quand même des inégalités
incontestablement les chiffres de
l'INSEE à et surtout pour les médecins
spécialistes entre les territoires les
écarts pour 100000 habitants dans
l'Hexagone vont de 75 à 650 alors que
faire on sait que ces inégalités
territoriales elles amplifient encore
les inégalités de sociale de santé que
nous connaissons déjà alors je vous le
dis moi de manière très humble là je
n'ai pas de certitude sur ce sujet j'ai
même changé d'avis en vérité après avoir
interrogé beaucoup de citoyens d'usagers
des professionnels de santé lui des
rapports regardez aussi ce qui se fait à
l'étranger et je pense que oui dans les
années qui viennent si ce n'est
aujourd'hui nous devons avancer vers
davantage de régulation il y a une
palette de solutions pour ça il y a ces
amendements là il y en a d'autres un peu
plus loin y compris avec une clause de
grand-père pour les jeunes
professionnels il y en a aussi qui vont
sur le conventionnement sélectif je
pense que c'est utile que nous ayons ce
débat je n'ignore pas les réserves qui
s'expriment ici y compris du
gouvernement et de la majorité mais je
pense que c'est notre travail de
législateur à travers cette proposition
de loi que de pouvoir débattre au fond
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député
pour te vos avis sur ces amendements
oui madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues
je vais d'abord rassurer mon collègue
Thierry Benoît je parle toujours avec
beaucoup de sagesse toujours
alors merci j'ai entendu l'ensemble des
exposés qui ont été faits et
effectivement
il constate tout que notre système a
failli on le sait que notre système est
en crise on le sait que notre système
provoque des inégalités d'accès et pour
autant d'un système de santé dont la
galaxie aux soins est un des fondements
et un des principes et aussi une des
valeurs à laquelle on tient et les
Français avec nous on sait que
aujourd'hui effectivement face à aux
soins face à certaines spécialités face
à l'accès aux généralistes mais parfois
même face à l'accès à l'hôpital les
chances ne sont pas les mêmes pour les
Français selon les territoires où ils
vivent et tout cela effectivement nous
rend profondément nous met profondément
en colère nous le savons
pour autant pour autant pour autant une
fois dresser le constat et comme on le
dit depuis deux jours on essaye
collectivement à l'occasion de ce de
cette de ce débat de trouver des des
réponses qui pourraient être j'allais
dire pragmatique en tous les cas des
réponses qui permettraient surtout de
concrètement améliorer l'accès aux soins
pour pour les Français
nous sommes nous parlons et nous l'avons
évoqué les uns les autres nous parlons
d'un système notre système de santé qui
est profondément fragile et qui est
menacé par la pénurie de soignants c'est
bien ça le mot on parle de bureaucratie
on parle de rigidité on parle de
difficulté financières on parle parfois
rationalité budgétaire mais au fond du
fond le vrai sujet c'est que nous avons
peu de soignants pour soigner et pour
prendre en charge les Français moi je
voudrais quand même vous donner quelque
chiffres parce que c'est important au
moment où on débat de sujets aussi
majeurs qu'on est tous en tête
effectivement quelques chiffres les
généralistes il y en a de moins en moins
on peut parler des spécialistes bien sûr
mais les généralistes c'est ceux qui
sont au plus près de nos concitoyens
c'est ceux qui sont dans les territoires
c'est la porte d'entrée dans le système
de santé c'est ceux qui accompagnent les
Français à toute leurs étapes de leur
vie souvent le médecin de famille c'est
celui qui connaît effectivement qui vous
a connu jeune et qui vous accompagne
pendant quelques années le généraliste
il est de moins en moins nombreux ils
sont de moins en moins nombreux pardon
ils sont de moins en moins nombreux on
en a perdu presque un peu moins de 10000
ces 10 dernières années et on sait que
malheureusement jusqu'en 2026 même en
2030 la décrue va continuer va même
s'accélérer
plus de 25% des généralistes ont plus de
60 ans c'est-à-dire que d'ici 2030 la
plupart vont partir à la retraite et
certains ont étirés parce que quand on
dit plus de 60 ans il y en a beaucoup
qui après 70 ans continuent à consulter
vous le savez
il faudra attendre 200030 pour que nous
retrouvions les chiffres de 2006 105000
généralistes 105.000 généralistes en
2006 donc nous sommes au début
effectivement d'un rebond mais d'un an
très très long rebond et donc
effectivement peut-être pour répondre à
ce qui a été dit peut-être que à cette
dans ces années là peut-être que dans
les années 2030 il faudra mettre en
place un système qui nous permet
d'éviter les erreurs du passé quelles
ont été ses erreurs du passé et bien de
voir effectivement s'installer dans des
territoires qui sont parfois les mêmes
dans des territoires peu nombreux de
voir s'installer de te voir se
concentrer l'offre médicale parce que
effectivement la main visible du marché
n'a pas bien joué et effectivement
l'installation et c'est ce sont ils se
sont éparpillés aux quatre coins du
territoire en privilégiant certains
territoires les plus attractifs alors
oui je suis pas contre effectivement
qu'on se comprenne le temps et avec les
professionnels pour inventer un système
qui permet et bien d'assurer une
meilleure répartition des forces
médicales dans le territoire mais
l'enjeu d'ici là et c'est là-dessus que
je voudrais insister de d'ici là contenu
de la des difficultés démographiques
c'est de garder avec nous nos soignants
nous en avons de moins en moins je l'ai
expliqué j'ai donné les chiffres si nous
perdons nos soignants alors nous aurons
pas réussi effectivement à améliorer
l'accès aux soins des Français et donc
c'est un message de confiance c'est un
message de confiance et de
responsabilité que l'on donne aussi aux
soignants à travers cette proposition
loi et notamment maintenant au moment de
se débat mais au-delà de l'ensemble des
soignants moi je pense aux jeunes
puisque finalement cette discussion sur
l'installation c'est un système qui va
s'appliquer aux jeunes aux jeunes qui
sont dans la dans les études de médecine
et Dieu sait qu'elles sont longues mais
aux jeunes aussi qui envisagent de
s'engager dans les études de médecine or
nous sommes face à une profession et une
attractivité qui est sur le fil du
rasoir là aussi permettez-moi de donner
quelques éléments
je reste sur les généralistes parce que
je le redis les généralistes sont
importants et sont des maillons majeurs
dans notre système de santé les
généralistes attirent de moins en moins
et ce qu'on sait que il y a simplement
il y a 6 fois plus de de de spécialistes
qui ont été formés ces dix dernières
années pardon que deux généralistes
c'est-à-dire que l'attractivité du
métier de généraliste et de moins en
moins forte chez chez les jeunes et
pourtant on en a besoin est-ce que vous
savez que le nombre de généralistes qui
partent à l'étranger c'est 10%
aujourd'hui ils étaient 2%, il y a il y
a 10 ans c'est à dire qu'en 10 ans on a
fait on a on a effectivement détourné du
métier de généraliste
permettez-moi d'aller au bout de mon
raisonnement permettez-moi d'aller au
bout de mon raisonnement on a
effectivement et on a effectivement
poussé nos généralistes à quitter la
France pour des raisons qui sont
peut-être pas des bonnes raisons mais
les faits sont là écoutons les faits
et 20% des jeunes et des 20% des jeunes
généralistes au lieu de s'installer à
l'hôpital en libéral va préférer aller
s'installer en entreprise elle préfère
aller dans des institutions c'est-à-dire
à des endroits où il ne croisera aucun
patient il fera son métier dans des
laboratoires et ailleurs mais ne
croisera aucun patient donc je pardon
mais il sera quelque part entre
guillemets
inutile aux soins et à la prise en
charge des Français ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'à travers ce débat c'est
d'abord un signal que l'on envoie à la
jeunesse vous êtes tous très attentifs
sur ces vents et vous avez raison
d'adresser des signaux positifs à la
jeunesse par rapport à leur métier par
rapport à l'engagement dans leur société
par rapport à leurs conditions de vie
actuelle et future le débat que nous
avons là c'est pas un débat vis-à-vis de
ceux qui depuis 30 ans s'entassent dans
certaines villes attractives
effectivement et qui quoi qu'il arrive
resteront dans ces villes attractives et
dérouleront leurs carrière comme bon
leur Sion dans ces villes attractives je
parle de tous ces médecins qui sont
effectivement en surpopulation dans
certains territoires mais là nous
parlons pas d'eux parce que cela on va
pas les déranger moi je parle des jeunes
et je parle de ceux qui effectivement
demain sont l'av partir de la prise en
charge des Français alors qu'on leur
demande pas trop de porter le chapeau de
ce que les générations précédentes n'ont
pas fait qu'on leur demande pas trop de
porter la responsabilité de ce que les
gouvernements passés n'ont pas aux
effets peut-être qu'on leur demande pas
trop de porter la responsabilité d'un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements que
vous avez tous rappelés que vous avez
tous rappelés à juste titre mais qui
aujourd'hui il serait il serait
responsable voilà c'est le message que
je souhaitais donner bien sûr je suis
défavorable à ces amendements je ne suis
pas défavorable au principe demain d'un
système qui soit réfléchi avec les
professionnels pour veiller une
meilleure organisation de l'offre de
soins dans le territoire mais
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est posé ce débat
me paraît trop pas assez préparé pas
assez et surtout complètement
inconciliables avec le choc
démographique que j'ai que j'ai
développé merci avis des favorable merci
Monsieur le Ministre vos avis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés
tout d'abord merci d'avoir amené ce
débat dans l'hémicycle
vous savez avec ma collègue Agnès Firmin
le Bodo nous nous sommes engagés en
arrivant à lutter contre toutes les
inégalités d'accès à la santé et les
inégalités territoriales d'accès à la
santé sont certainement les plus
visibles mais aussi les plus complexes à
gérer même si nous sommes tous d'accord
sur le diagnostic alors
je respecte bien entendu mesdames et
messieurs vos convictions et je vous
remercie de l'expression que vous avez
eu pour les défendre vous le savez je
serai défavorable à ses amendements et
vous le savez aussi je ne partage pas
cette cette conviction je ne viendrai
pas dans les débats sur les chiffres ni
sur les exemples étrangers nucer les
exemples d'autres professions vous savez
comme moi que les chiffres on peut les
utiliser dans tous les sens que les
exemples étrangers ne sont pas
transposables à notre situation c'est
d'ailleurs dans le rapport de l'adresse
et que la comparaison avec des
professions qui ne sont pas en tension
ne tient pas non plus je reviendrai
surtout sur le message que vous adressez
avec ces amendements message aux
Français message aux professionnels de
santé
aux Français vous leur adresser un
message en disant tout ce qui a été fait
à servi à rien ou pas grand-chose et
nous avons là une solution qui va nous
permettre d'améliorer la situation et
demain vous aurez un médecin près de
chez vous dans les territoires ruraux ce
message c'est aussi permettez-moi de le
dire
stigmatiser des professionnels de santé
en leur disant vous n'avez pas fait le
travail
madame madame la députée madame la
députée j'ai souvent dans ma carrière
utiliser cette maxime quand on parle on
ne fait que répéter ce que l'on sait
déjà mais quand on écoute on a peut-être
une chance d'apprendre quelque chose je
vous remercie de me laisser exprimer mes
arguments
[Applaudissements]
cette cette solution elle apparaît comme
un écran de fumée un voile que l'on met
sur l'ensemble des autres solutions qui
elles fonctionnent j'aurai l'occasion
d'y revenir alors ma volonté est aussi
de vous dire et de dire à nos
concitoyens la vérité sur ce qui va se
passer
loin d'améliorer la situation ces
amendements s'ils sont votés vont
dégrader l'offre de soins ils vont la
dégrader de façon importante ils ne vont
pas à la dégrader demain après-demain
ils vont la dégrader dans les heures qui
viennent
comment celle-ci va-t-elle être dégradée
tout d'abord par des refus
d'installation c'est déjà le cas ça va
s'accentuer dès demain des départs en
retraite qui vont s'accentuer alors que
notre objectif est justement de garder
ses médecins plus longtemps en activité
des conventionnements qui vont créer ce
que personne ne souhaite à savoir cette
médecine à deux vitesses
le salariat qui va se développer pas
forcément dans les territoires
l'évolution vers un système qui verra
disparaître la médecine libérale qui est
pourtant un des piliers vous le savez
notre système de santé on parlait tout à
l'heure d'expérience étrangère je ne
pense pas que l'exemple actuel du NHS
anglais soit l'exemple vers lequel nous
voulons aller
les médecins ne sont pas captifs encore
moins les médecins généralistes ils vont
se diriger vers d'autres professions et
ils ont la possibilité de le faire à
l'issue de leur
spécialité de médecine générale mais
également avant vous le savez
certainement il y a ce qu'on appelle le
droit aux remords donc des jeunes qui
sont déjà inscrits en médecine générale
vont s'en aller dès demain pour une
autre spécialité et puis je ne parle
même pas de l'étranger qui fait les yeux
doux à nos médecins parce qu'ils sont
particulièrement bien formés dire la
vérité c'est aussi dire que un médecin
de moins dans un centre-ville bien de
thé ce n'est pas un médecin de plus dans
une commune rurale de Mayenne ou
d'Ardèche c'est plus probablement deux
médecins de moins partout et Monsieur
brin vous m'expliquez ce qu'elle a la
ruralité vous l'ignorez probablement
mais j'ai passé plus de 20 ans de ma
carrière en Meuse je crois que c'est un
territoire qui répond bien à la
définition de la ruralité
alors après le message aux Français quel
message vous portez aux professionnels
de santé
merci pour votre investissement
quotidien dans un système de santé
dégradé dont ils ne sont pas
responsables
je n'ai pas entendu ça sur ces bancs
merci pour votre gestion de la crise
sanitaire nous vous avez fait nous vous
avons fait confiance vous avez réagi
vous avez vacciné vous nous avez aidé à
passer cette crise n'est pas entendu ça
non plus c'est dommage
ce que j'entends c'est de la
stigmatisation
stigmatisation des professionnels
qualifiés et des modes sont pas là mais
les fragissons qualifiés d'immatures
d'irresponsables voire même d'enfants
gâtés pour lesquels nous payons leurs
études et qui ne donne rien en retour
alors même que la solution elle est dans
ce texte elle est dans le ce texte qui a
été défendu par le rapporteur la
solution c'est la confiance c'est la
responsabilité or ceci n'est pas une
solution anodine que vous proposez dans
ces amendements ce n'est pas je suis
désolé de vous le dire un coup pour voir
cet amendement s'il est voté c'est une
perte durable de la confiance des
professionnels de santé et comment
comptez-vous comment imaginez-vous
engagez cette grande réforme du système
de santé sans la confiance des
professionnels vous parliez monsieur
Favennec d'expérimenter dans vos propos
s'il vous plaît n'expérimentons pas ne
jouons pas à pile ou face avec notre
système de santé ne jouant pas à pile ou
face avec la santé des Français
alors ce qui marche ce qui marche vous
le savez je bien sûr les difficultés
sont là et tout doit être fait pour y
remédier vous avez parlé d'incitation il
faut des aides claires ciblés c'est
l'objectif de se guichet unique dont
nous n'avons parlé
monsieur Garraud vous nous dites que les
incitations ne fonctionnent pas pourquoi
ne fonctionne-t-elle pas c'est peut-être
ça aussi qui est intéressant elle ne
fonctionne pas parce que nous avions ce
numerus clausus numerus clausus que vous
avez les uns et les autres défendus et
qui a été enlevé par 7 majorité
favorisant également l'exercice plus RIP
professionnel cet exercice rubrip
professionnel territorial c'est ce qui
est défendu dans cette PPL cet exercice
pluriprofessionnel avait des
consultations avancées avec des maisons
de santé plus riprofessionnelles avec
des équipes de soins c'est ce que nous
demande les professionnels sur le
terrain il faut les écouter c'est
également du gain de temps médical du
gain de temps soignant le partage des
compétences les assistants médicaux qui
je vous le répète permettent de prendre
en charge 10% de patients en plus les
IPA les infirmières azalées les
plateformes de rendez-vous également on
en parle trop peu ces plateformes de
rendez-vous qui permettent de diviser
par deux les rendez-vous non-honorés qui
permettent également d'améliorer de 13%,
le nombre de patients pris par un
médecin
messieurs garrot five Nike dans votre
département vous le savez à cran tous
ces systèmes sont mis en place et cela
fonctionne cela fonctionne très bien pas
dans le reste du département mais
puisque nous en sommes à échanger des
médecins entre les territoires êtes-vous
prêts à Laval de proposer des médecins
dans le nord du département
l'autre solution qui fonctionne et vous
le savez c'est l'augmentation des
troupes le peu de troupes que nous avons
il faut les garder il faut chercher à
les augmenter c'est le maintien de
l'activité des médecins jeunes retraités
c'est ce que nous avons pris comme
décision avec le cumul emploi retraite
nous avons besoin que ces médecins
restent nous ne pouvons pas les laisser
déplaquer prendre leur retraite par un
signal négatif porté par votre
amendement c'est également la quatrième
année pour les étudiants en médecine
générale je vous le rappelle
3600 de ces jeunes étudiants vont
arriver en 2016 dans nos territoires
sont enfin les stages précoces dans les
zones les cordées de la réussite
ce qui marche c'est travailler avec les
professionnels de santé pour améliorer
notre système ce n'est pas travailler
contre les professionnels de santé
l'ascension de cette face nord qui est
représentée par la refondation du
système de santé ne se fera pas sans les
professionnels je sais que vous le savez
je sais que dans ces bancs même ceux qui
ont signé cet amendement vous avez un
doute vous avez un doute sur
l'efficacité réelle de ce dispositif je
n'ai aucun doute et vous pouvez en être
certain sur l'effet négatif qu'il va
avoir enfin vous vous réclamez à juste
titre d'une démarche transpartisane
permettez-moi simplement de préciser que
l'opposition assez texte l'opposition à
ses amendements est également
transpartisane je répète donc un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ses
amendements pour ne pas détruire notre
système de santé je vous remercie
merci monsieur
j'ai plusieurs demandes
j'ai plusieurs demandes de prise de
parole dans ce sera une par groupe
ce qui est déjà pas mal je pense
madame Moutchou pour le groupe horizon
pardon
sinon on fait un pour un contre si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord
et bah ce sera un pour un conte madame
Moutchou merci
merci madame la Présidente alors en ce
qui me concerne en ce qui me concerne ce
sera
je vous le dis et d'ailleurs je vous le
dis de manière je vous le dis je vous le
dis d'autant plus aisément que je ne
suis pas médecin et donc on ne me taxera
pas de corporatisme et je vous le dis
d'autant plus facilement que je vis sur
un territoire qui est lui-même un désert
médical le Val-d'Oise département de la
grande couronne département de la
banlieue parisienne dans lequel on
souffre également terriblement demande
de médecins mais j'ai entendu les
arguments
j'ai confronté les points de vie je me
suis documenté et j'en ai déduit que ça
n'était pas une solution où ça n'est pas
la bonne solution mes chers collègues
alors
d'abord il n'y a rien d'évident il n'y a
franchement rien d'évident à faire peser
le choix de mauvaise politique publique
du passé sur les médecins ça n'est pas
évident et si nous devions le faire si
nous devions le faire il faudrait que
nous ayons la certitude que nous
produirions des résultats et ce n'est
pas le cas un médecin de moi en
centre-ville ou dans les zones surdosées
ce mot ne voulant rien dire ça ne veut
pas dire un médecin de plus à la
campagne ça n'est pas vrai en revanche
ça veut certainement dire un décompvent
de plus et ça c'est un risque énorme qui
est pris mes chers collègues il faut le
dire nous allons priver des millions de
Français de soins de soins remboursés
nous allons créer ou aggraver une
médecine à deux vitesses nous allons
affaiblir une profession dont nous avons
le plus grand besoin je dis attention à
ses effets de bord je préfère donc mes
chers collègues
convaincus que ce système n'est pas
efficace que nous travaillons ensemble à
autre chose nous avons voté des réformes
elles prennent du temps elles prennent
du temps nous n'y pouvons rien
travaillons à dégager du temps médical
pour les médecins parce que ça n'est pas
que le nombre de médecins qui compte ce
sont aussi les créneaux travaillons
ensemble avec les médecins et madame la
Présidente je conclus je veux dire tout
le respect que nous avons aussi pour les
médecins donc nous connaissons les
difficultés d'exercice merci
Monsieur Bricout
merci mesdames la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur avec mes
collègues nous costaudons que non
seulement nous manque présence médicale
mais les professionnels de santé sont
évidemment mal répartis sur nos
territoires à la première problématique
une première réponse a été apportée on
est passé du numéro slausus au numéro à
Perthus par contre sur les
problématiques de la répartition le
choix d'installation se fait en fin de
compte sur la seule attractivité des
territoires ainsi malgré tous les
efforts d'accompagnement des
collectivités les inégalités
territoriales se creusent les chiffres
parlent d'eux-mêmes entre 2010 et 2023
c'est plus 27% de médecins qui par
habitant dans les Hautes-Alpes et -
15,7% dans la Creuse sur cette même
période
incontestablement il faut des solutions
nouvelles c'est l'objet de cet article
qui propose une régulation
face à cette régulation je vais d'abord
assurer les soignants il n'y a pas
quelque part péril on la demeure en leur
demande juste d'arrêter de s'installer
là où les soignants sont simplement trop
nombreux rien de ce dans le d'autant
plus qu'il reste 87% du territoire en
France où ils seront quand même
accueillis les bras ouverts au final
tout ça reste du bon sens et de la
solidarité territoriale loin de nous
toute idée de coercition par contre
monsieur le ministre vous nous opposez
des arguments qui m'interrogent vous
argumentez que face à cette régulation
nos médecins seraient prêts à tout
seraient prêt à ne plus installer à
quitter la profession abandonner 6
millions de Français en grande détresse
qu'il serait prêt d'ailleurs à tout
malgré leur première vocation malgré des
études longues malgré la signature du
serment d'Hippocrate vous argumenterez
qu'il serait même prêt à quitter la
France personnellement moi j'y crois pas
et appuyez votre argumentation sur
l'idée que vous faites de la profession
et quelque part malsaine et regrettable
je vous invite monsieur le ministre à
rester comme moi confiant l'avenir de la
France soyez-en d'abord persuadés il n'y
aura pas de société apaisée
bienveillante
sans l’évocation et les solidarités
territoriales et humaines
la parole est à Monsieur Houssin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre je voulais réagir à ses
amendements
ne comprennent pas vu que j'avais dit
une du coup ce sera un pour un compte et
que tous les rappels règlement sortaient
que je voyais que du coup ça n'irait pas
plus vite ce sera une prise de parole
par groupe et juste pour que vous
n'imaginiez pas que je fuis face au
combat cette séance était normalement
présidée par ma collègue muchu je l'ai
dépanné parce qu'elle avait une autre
chose à faire donc là celle qui va
reprendre la séance je ne suis pas face
à vous chers collègues je rends juste la
présidence à ma collègue
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
je voulais réagir sur la forme à ses
amendements pour rappeler qu'il n'y a
pas de groupe transpartisans sur le
sujet des déserts médicaux il ne peut
pas y avoir de groupe transpartisans en
excluant les 88 députés du rassemblement
national car si l'on fait une carte des
déserts médicaux et une carte du votre
rassemblement national on s'aperçoit que
les députés du rassemblement national
souvent sont ceux qu'on choisit les
habitants des déserts médicaux pour le
représenté
sur le fond votre amendement pose les
groupes il oppose les territoires et il
oppose les médecins et leurs patients
c'est un amendement en réalité qui a des
motivations très partisanes et très
électoraliste vous voulez faire croire
aux habitants des déserts médicaux qu'on
va régler leurs problèmes d'un coup de
baguette magique la réalité c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de zone surdotée à vider au
profit des zones soudées la réalité et
vous le savez c'est que le remet des
pires que le mal je le dis d'autant plus
facilement que je suis élu d'un
département l'heure qui est
particulièrement concerné par les
déserts médicaux j'ai d'ailleurs
moi-même été partisan de cette solution
de facilité avant de la confronter à la
réalité et de constater qu'elle a plus
d'effets pervers que bénéfique
la réalité c'est que vous allez
détourner des jeunes médecins de la
médecine de ville alors qu'on en a
fondamentalement besoin la réalité c'est
que vous allez favoriser le
déconventionnement et donc une médecine
à deux vitesses au profit des plus
riches la réalité c'est que nous
manquons de médecin dans les déserts
médicaux mais surtout nous manquons de
médecin tout court à cause de la
politique que vous avez mené pendant des
décennies aujourd'hui il est urgent de
moduler les tarifs de la consultation à
la hausse dans les déserts médicaux sans
surcoût pour le patient pour attirer des
praticiens sans dégoûter les autres il
est urgent de former davantage de
médecins actuellement car le numerus
aperçu reste extrêmement insuffisant il
est urgent d'orienter les jeunes
originaires de nos déserts médicaux vers
la médecine pour qu'ils y exercent il
est urgent de décharger nos médecins de
tâches et de certificat médicaux non
prioritaires en conclusion on ne peut
pas contraindre les médecins quand il
n'y a plus de médecins quand il n'y a
plus de médecins on en forme on en
attire et on priorise leur action
je vous remercie monsieur le député
alors pour le groupe modem monsieur
Vigier monsieur civil j'ai deux j'ai
deux demandes alors attendez attendez
attendez monsieur Vigier qui s'est
inscrit le premier
alors Monsieur Vigier qui a pris le
micro
[Applaudissements]
je suis dans la continuité de ce qui a
été décidé par la présidente que je ne
vais certainement pas déjuger c'est un
par groupe alors qui s'est inscrit le
premier c'est Jacqueline
merci le ministre monsieur le rapporteur
chacun a bien compris que c'est un
moment
particulièrement important il n'y a pas
de gagnant il y a pas de perdant il faut
avoir un peu d'humilité collective
depuis 40 ans on a volé des chèques en
échec il y a un ensemble président de la
République qui nous a expliqué une chose
vous savez c'était sur le chômage est-ce
qu'on a tout essayé est-ce que sur
l'action on a tout essayé non et vous
savez très bien monsieur le ministre que
ce que nous proposons n'est pas une
révolution culturelle tant s'en faut je
dis à Frédéric Valtou
qui lui-même sait que ce sujet de
régulation se pose parce que dans le
texte initial qu'il avait souhaité
porter il faisait référence à la
régulation il y a que ma mini qui n'est
pas parmi nous qui avait préparé un
texte ancien rapporteur général du
budget de la Sécu médecin
urgentiste et qui lui-même avait compris
qu'il fallait naturellement un moment ou
un autre franchir le seuil et puis le
président de la République lui-même
pardonnez-moi qui a prononcé ce mot
régulation à un moment ou un autre pour
vous dire que monsieur le ministre
il est des moments où il faut essayer
des voix qu'on a jamais essayé et nul ne
peut dire le contraire nul ne peut dire
le contraire
alors donc
osons ensemble essayons ensemble et je
dis enfin rassemblement national parce
que ce sujet est un sujet majeur dans
toutes les circonscriptions rurales et
bien une fois de plus vous aurez montré
que vous êtes dans le renoncement
national à tout moment jamais le courage
jamais au nom de quoi avec zéro
proposition alors il faut
à ce moment-là quel que soit les idées
des uns et des autres et moi je respecte
les avis contraires et je termine en
disant que ce Nicolas Sarkozy j'ai
déposé une proposition de loi j'ai été
battu si François Hollande j'ai été
battu sous Emmanuel Macron également
aujourd'hui de façon transpartisone
osant et réussissons
je vous remercie
pour le groupe les républicains monsieur
noder non c'est une part groupe monsieur
Sybille
merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues je voudrais faire un
propos en quatre points et au-delà de
tout corporatismes parce que si je peux
vous assurer que si cette mesure était
bonne je la vaut très mais je pense que
le remède est pire colmal je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi premièrement toutes
les circonscriptions de partout on
manque de médecin ça a été très bien dit
par différents groupes on ne va pas
limiter on va pas agir sur les médecins
quand ils sont plus en nombre et on va
surtout pas les rendre responsables de
30 ans d'errance de politique de santé
en France ces médecins qu'on
applaudissait pendant le covid on les
tient maintenant responsables la
troisième chose je ne suis pas d'accord
avec Monsieur Vigier sur le fait du
risque important qu'on prend beaucoup de
médecins vont se déconventionner on va
avoir une médecine à deux vitesses les
gens s'installeront où ils veulent mais
les passions ne seront plus remboursés
qui assumera dans ces permanences
d'avoir des patients qui ne peuvent pas
aller voir les médecins parce qu'ils ne
seront pas remboursés la troisième chose
c'est qu'effectivement il faut être
force de proposition ces forces de
propositions le groupe les républicains
on vous le fait monsieur le ministre
depuis un an avec une vraie suppression
de ce numerus à Perthus formulant le
autrement mettons en capacité sur les
demandes de territoire avec la
validation des élus locaux les places de
formation il faut naturellement des
médecins de formation il faut
naturellement des places dans les
universités il faut naturellement des
stages dans les cliniques chez dans les
cabinets donc tout ça nous pouvons le
faire tous ensemble et nous pouvons
aussi faire des passerelles entre les
paramédicaux qui ont fait cinq ans six
ans d'études et qui peuvent devenir
médecin en trois ans moyen-ant une
formation accélérée donc je crois que
c'est ça les bonnes mesures attention ça
a été dit et je regrette que Cyril il
active puisse pas prendre la parole ils
disaient très justement que 10000 postes
de médecins hospitaliers sont en
pourvoir il y a toute la fuite des
médecins à l'étranger il y a aussi tout
le changement le rapport au travail avec
la féminisation des professions le
rapport à la parentalité attention mes
chers collègues merci
beaucoup
la parole est à Madame bateau pour le
groupe écologiste
merci merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues il y a des arguments que l'on
entend depuis 20 ans entre temps la
situation sur le terrain c'est aggraver
au point que c'est aujourd'hui une
urgence de santé publique mais surtout
il y a un fait notable le fait notable
c'est des témoignages comme celui-ci je
suis en fin de carrière j'accompagne
actuellement un projet de maison de
santé plus dire ici plus de riz
disciplinaire pour transmettre ma
passionelle je suis maître de stage
depuis plus de 15 ans quand je lis les
propositions pour dire que des
incitations vont réussir à régler le
problème des déserts médicaux je dis que
c'est méconnaître complètement la
situation ma proposition c'est de
réguler la démographie médicale ce qui a
changé sur le terrain dans les
territoires que nous connaissons les uns
et les autres c'est qu'une partie du
corps médical aujourd'hui lui-même et
demandeur de mesure de régulation alors
chers collègues moi j'ai qu'une seule
chose à dire c'est que dans cet
assemblée dans le contexte politique
actuel quand des personnes aussi
différentes que les collègues qui sont
tous signataires de cette amendement
travail ensemble depuis le mois de
juillet
2022 chaque semaine font des auditions
font un tour de France des déserts
médicaux c'est parce qu'il y a une
urgence et une demande des citoyens et
j'appelle chacune et chacun un vote qui
dépasse tous les clivages et qui
montrent que la politique sert à quelque
chose pour régler les problèmes des gens
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur sangsue pour le
gros GDR
merci Madame merci madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous dites
que ça ne va pas et donc il ne faudrait
rien changer pas vous passez
faut vraiment changer quelque chose
voyez bien que depuis 20 ans on y arrive
pas monsieur le ministre vous nous
accusez de stigmatiser les
professionnels de santé je ne voudrais
pas vous rappeler que c'est vous qui
êtes fâché avec les médecins c'est vous
qui le reconnaissez pas leur engagement
c'est vous qui avez fait en sorte que
six syndicats de médecins ne signe pas
la convention avec vous pour l'assurance
maladie c'est tout simplement ça la
réalité alors arrêtez de nous promettre
l'Apocalypse il faut être sérieux
monsieur le ministre cette recherche
d'une solution de régulation légère et
largement partagée par nos concitoyens
partout le peuple en fait il suffit de
regarder les dizaines les centaines de
personnes qui poussent les portes de nos
permanences angoissée devant l'absence
de médecin traitant ou la possibilité
d'avoir une consultation d'ophtalmo ou
de dentiste dans toutes nos
circonscriptions nous sommes confrontés
à cela et cette situation est si
intenable que ce débat qui est
aujourd'hui tranché dans la population
parce que tout le monde le dit il faut
organiser la présence médicale
pourraient l'être ici de manière
positive dans notre émission tout
simplement nous sommes à un moment
crucial beaucoup de choses ont été
tentés pour contrer l'ineptie du
numérique clausus notamment par les élus
locaux mise en oeuvre de maisons de
santé pluridisciplinaire parfois vite
d'ailleurs création de centre de santé
incitation et monsieur le ministre nous
avons pas attendu ici chez moi à Vierzon
comme à Châteaudun chez Monsieur Vigier
comme à Laval chez Monsieur garrot nous
avons créé des structures pour permettre
de juguler les difficultés médicales
mais l'heure est venue d'envoyer un
signe qui dans un panel de solutions qui
est concernera aussi la démocratisation
des études médicales où l'intégration
des praticiens diplômes Union européenne
permettra enfin de redonner un espoir
une visibilité à nos concitoyens faisons
tous ensemble oeuvres utile comme nous
l'avons fait dans le groupe de travail
transpartisans je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur garrot pour le
groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
vraiment en quelques mots dire à
Monsieur le Ministre que le
catastrophisme qu'il a mis en avant ne
convain personne sur sur ces bancs pour
des raisons et je le dis de façon très
tranquille pour des raisons extrêmement
simples parce que la régulation
elle a fait ses preuves elle a fait ses
preuves à l'étranger si et seulement si
elle est articulée elle est combinée à
d'autres mesures des mesures que
d'ailleurs nous soutenons dans la
proposition de loi du rapporteur Valtou
en effet il faut combiner régulation et
mesure d'incitation et c'est ce que nous
proposons notre proposition notre
amendement vient donc enrichir donner de
l'efficacité sa pleine efficacité aux
politiques que vous proposez par
ailleurs c'est très important de
rappeler cela ensuite le débat il porte
sur
le moment
de la mise en oeuvre de cette régulation
vous savez avec les membres du groupe
transpartisans nous avons fait ce tour
de France des déserts médicaux depuis
des semaines depuis des mois et à chaque
fois la même attente le même cris de
détresse de nos concitoyens qui nous
demandent instamment qui nous supplie
d'agir et en effet c'est maintenant
qu'il faut agir et quelle sera la
première efficacité de la mesure de
régulation extrêmement équilibrée nuancé
que nous proposons ce sera de stopper
l'aggravation des inégalités qui
semblent inexorable depuis 10-15 ans
alors je m'adresse à tous les collègues
bien sûr qu'il y a des résistances bien
sûr qu'il y a des oppositions bien sûr
qu'il y a des conservatismes nous
entendons tout cela mais
ce que nous devons surtout entendre ce
que nous devons surtout écouter ce sont
les Français ce sont les patients qui
sont sans médecin ce sont ceux qui n'ont
plus d'espoir et qui n'ont qu'une seule
attente croire à nouveau en l'efficacité
de l'action publique c'est ce que nous
demandons c'est ce que nous allons voter
je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Maudet pour le
groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
je pour les collègues qui qui hésitent
aujourd'hui je voulais vous dire que il
faut quand même mesurer la mesure enfin
qu'il faudrait mesurer le fait
exceptionnel d'avoir un texte que nous
avons signé et puis des amendements
cosignés par quel 90% des groupes de
cette Assemblée nationale et je pense
que c'est aussi redonner ses lettres de
noblesse à notre Assemblée nationale que
de voter ce type d'amendement ensuite en
revanche c'est aussi un amendement pour
dire merci au médecin faut pas s'y
tromper aujourd'hui il y a des médecins
dans les déserts médicaux qui sont seuls
isolés qui auraient bien besoin de
collègues et cet amendement va dans ce
sens là c'est leur apporter des renforts
c'est pas du tout contre les médecins au
contraire
maintenant il s'agit aussi de
dédramatiser d'une part si la démarche
est exceptionnelle je crois que la
mesure en fait les moins il s'agit
aujourd'hui vous dites que 87% de la
France est un désert médical est bien
soit donc nous permettons au médecin de
s'installer dans presque 90 % du pays
seulement nous voulons éviter que les
inégalités s'aggravent et que certains
s'installent dans les 10% restants c'est
ni plus ni moins que ça ensuite comme le
disait mon collègue Christophe Marion de
renaissance c'était une promesse
d'Emmanuel Macron la régulation c'était
une de ses promesses en 2022
un autre point mais en 2021 les députés
de la République en marche 50 députés de
la République en marche signé ce texte
adressé au ministre de la Santé
l'urgence est de pouvoir soigner les
habitants de nos territoires pas dans 10
ans mais dès demain c'est pourquoi nous
vous proposons d'accepter une relative
contrainte dans l'installation des
généralistes sur le territoire rien
d'exceptionnel nous ne faisons que
reprendre des mesures que par certains
d'entre vous ont porté en fait dans
l'Assemblée nationale et enfin dernier
point monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure vous avez cité l'adresse donc
votre ministère comme pourquoi les
mesures de régulation ne
fonctionneraient pas et bien moi je vais
citer donc l'adresse votre ministère les
exemples internationaux vont globalement
dans le sens d'un impact positif d'une
politique de régulation des
installations sur l'équité de la
distribution géographique l'autre
ministère dit le contraire de ce que
vous dites monsieur le ministre et je
cherche pas là à vous mettre en défaut
je cherche à convaincre les autres
collègues qui pensent qu'il va y avoir
une situation catastrophique derrière
non ce n'est pas vrai mais on a une
petite chance aujourd'hui de ne pas
aggraver les inégalités dans le pays et
d'un dernier mot aujourd'hui on peut
s'étonner mais peut-être pas tant que ça
que le seul groupe qui va voter contre
cet amendement c'est rassemblement
national contre les zones rurales
et la parole est à madame la Présidente
berger pour le groupe Renaissance
merci merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur
nous sommes ici tous parlementaires et
donc tous ces lunes de nos territoires
et tous convaincus qu'en effet l'urgence
la priorité numéro 1 pour les Français
c'est bien la question de la santé s'il
y avait une formule magique s'il y avait
une proposition magique alors elle
aurait été non seulement proposée mais
déjà déjà voté à l'unanimité dans cette
émission et la proposition qui nous est
faite aujourd'hui n'est pas une
proposition magique elle est au
contraire une proposition qui risque
d'aggraver la situation pourquoi pour
une raison simple en disant en disant
45000 médecins ont été diplômés seuls
5000 se sont installés en libéral si
vous demain vous essayez de les
contraindre plus il s'installeront moins
c'est ça l'effet immédiat qu'il se
produira
deuxième chose vous allez dire
évidemment à des familles à des
personnes qui ont fait 10 ans d'études
qui n'auront plus la liberté de choisir
le territoire dans lequel il s'installe
ça offre un des principes des valeurs
auxquelles nous sommes attachés
évidemment la question s'il vous plaît
un peu de calme enfin mes chers
collègues j'ai une question et une seule
pour défendre cet argument vous avez été
nombreux à parler de zones sur denses
deux zones surdosées est-ce qu'il y a
ici un sol parlementaire alors que la
Seine-Saint-Denis et le département le
plus carencé un seul parlementaire qui
peut lever la main et dire j'ai trop de
médecins en généraliste dans mon
département enlevez-moi des médecins
parce qu'à la fin c'est ça qui va se
produire madame la Présidente c'est un
jeu à somme nulle on va diplômé des
médecins on va les enlever dans des
territoires pour espérer les à
ré-attribuer dans d'autres il n'iront
patient installer et à la fin ce qui
voteront pour Hiro expliqué dans leur
territoire pourquoi il y aura moins de
médecins je vous remercie je vous
remercie
et tous les groupes tous les groupes se
sont exprimés nous allons pouvoir passer
au vote alors il se trouve que dans la
discussion commune seul le sous un
moment n'est pas par scrutin public
c'est le
1178 je le mets donc aux voix à main
levée s'il vous plaît sous un amendement
1178 double la vie défavorable qui est
pour
[Musique]
qui est contre
il n'est pas adopté et nous procédons
votre par scrutin public sur les
amendements 1 et identiques double avis
défavorable scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
résultat votants 304 exprimé 295
majorité 148 pour 127 contre 168
l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas adopté
[Applaudissements]